the big day now is 11 ways of infection
wearing a mask and how much time you
have becomes available to you there is a
general atmosphere of panic in India
regarding carbon 19 that people in
Europe would ask me to send them this
this is what streets will look like here
in France for at least two weeks because
the country is under lockdown and the
peak of the epidemic is at least a few
weeks away those preparations nothing is
normal here in Serbia anymore
streets are empty shops are closed and
people start to worry about their
economic future from the beginning of
the crisis Israel has taken drastic
steps to slow down the spread of kovat
19 Israelis returning from any country
have to go straight into self quarantine
for 14 days foreigners cannot enter the
country unless they have a place to
quarantine the countries under partial
lockdown schools malls restaurants and
cultural places are closed the
Palestinian Authority has also put in
place strict measures there is a lot of
worry about a possible outbreak of the
virus in the closed of Gaza Strip
[Music]
Istanbul is adapting to life under
coronavirus even the city's beloved
coffee shops are now shuttered along
with bars theatres cinemas the schools
too have been closed for at least two
weeks and the city's mosques have
canceled prayers this is a city adapting
to a new life the number of coronavirus
cases is steadily increasing in Pakistan
yet we see the life goes on pretty
normally here in the city of Karachi
people are not following the health
directives they are taking it pretty
lightly and if they continue to do it
Pakistan could be the next epicenter of
the coronavirus and the next few days
are very crucial on how Pakistan is
going to deal with the coronavirus
situation there is a general atmosphere
of panic in India regarding carbon 19
across many states schools malls and
movie theaters have been shut down and
companies have switched to Delhi working
while experts claim that India is not
conducting enough tests the government
says that they are taking all possible
measures to contain the spread of the
virus
[Music]
Malaysia begins 14 days of restricted
movement now except under special
circumstances foreigners are not allowed
into the country Malaysians are not
allowed to leave a country people were
hoarding food the government asks the
public please do not do this there's
enough food to go around for everyone as
long as people do not hoard food it
looks like now people are following
through on this now I spoken to a number
of Malaysians who tell me they are
comfortable with the government's
decision despite the inconveniences of
these 14 days that restrict the movement
but they believe that in the long run it
is the best thing for their health and
the best thing for the country
[Music]
after seemingly containing the virus
here in Hong Kong
the big fear now is second waves of
infections there's already been a surge
in recent days of imported cases
sometimes now taking status or shut down
the outside life remains relatively calm
in Taiwan panic is rarely seen here /
vigilance has been
the very beginning of the outbreak
wearing a mask and temperature checks
have become the daily routine on the
island
[Music]
South Korea appears to be making some
progress in its battle against the
corona virus as you can see here the
streets and sidewalks the capital seem
to have sort of regular traffic although
honestly it's far from the norm there
remains concern regarding cluster
outbreaks though here in the capital
Seoul still the main point is over the
past week in particular we've seen a
decline in the confirmed coronavirus
cases announced with fewer than a
hundred coming out each day South
Koreans seem to be prepared though for
an ongoing sort of containment and
mitigation South Korean schools that was
announced this week will remain closed
through April 6th and the government is
encouraging people still to stay indoors
banning large gatherings and of course
always calling on everyone to stay clean
[Music]
South Africa declared the outbreak and
national disaster schools closed many
land borders closed people from
high-risk countries are not allowed to
enter anymore but the key question here
is will the health sector be able to
cope with an increasing number of
infections I could never have imagined
that people in Europe would ask me
to send them this hand sanitizers from
Nigeria but nothing is normal these days
here in West Africa a region where
people already based infrastructure and
security challenges they now watch in
disbelief as people are fighting over
twilit paper in parts of the world
considered much better off so far
there's no panic here is only a small
number of cases have been confirmed
across the region so are we lucky people
ask me or simply much better prepared
with lessons learned from the Ebola
crisis and as you look over here at this
newspaper stand you will not find the
corona virus in the main headlines but
rather the death toll from an explosion
here in Lagos ordinary citizens appear
to be less concerned about catching the
corona virus themselves and more
about economic impact the spread of the
virus in other parts of the world may
have on them Columbia is nervous with
the government announcing more and more
drastic measures every day there's
little trust in its ability to actually
enforce them people also fear that a
spike in cases might lead to the
collapse of an already unstable
healthcare system we're in Georgetown
Washington DC and normally what you see
here is bumper-to-bumper traffic traffic
jam day and night and people on the
sidewalks all over the place now it's
virtually deserted this is the corona
virus seeping through the cracks of what
was the American lives just days ago now
this is all going to change
[Music]